hãy nhảy lại gạo cho đủ ý kiến sâu rộ, thực chất về hiện trạm trên bọn quanh hệ.
Đất chỉ cho rằng thái nước vẫn còn nhiều dự đi ở tắc,
và tinh tuần quanh hệ Việt Nam, lên bằng a sẽ tiếp tục phát triển tiếp cửh
của hợp với những nhiều gầu phát triển của hai đơn nước.
Hãy thủ chưởng đã tra đủ và thống nhất phát tâm,
nâng tầm thật tắc khi tế thật mại đấu từ chở thành nguy nhỏ,
diễn phòng trong một tác sống phương,
trên thái hợp qua hiếp định thương mại tru gồm rối Việt Nam và linh mình kích đea au.
Mời cửa hơn nữa thì chường, các bạn hẳng sức khẩu của nhau,
thúc đẩy có hoa đậu tru sống phương.
Thái bên đi nhận, giữ thành quả đã đạt được trong một tác năng lượng rộ khi,
nhưng mạnh, hợp tác năng lượng rộ khi ra linh vực chuyển thống,
biểu tượng hợp tắc được quả giữa hai nước,
và hẳng định quyết tâm nâng tầm linh vực hợp tắc chỉ lực này,
trên thái hợp quả cán sửa hợp tắc thành chốt.
Bây kện đó, hãy bình thống rất sớm nghiên cứu,
mở giọng quả hệ hợp tắc trong các lý vực tăng lượng mởi,
năng lượng sạch năng lượng đại đạo.
Nó ngó cho chuyển đổi sành, phát triển mình bước.
Thái nhà lãnh đạo hoàn ngân và hợp lực được kỳ kết thịt đình
giới chính dụng Việt Nam và chính dụng liên vật nà.
Về hợp tắc xây dựng nhà bại định hành nhân tại vệ nà.
Làm bước kỳn quan trọng trong hợp tắc sống phương,
trên lĩnh vực tăng lượng rộn rộn rộn,
biểu bức khỏe bình và tinh tuần.
Đây sẽ là công trình bật tượng mới cho tình giữ gì dịch tạm và lĩnh vật nà.
Khai thu tưởng thống nhất, đưa qua hợp và công vệ,
chở thành một chủ của tượng mới,
nhất chỉ thu bệ trụ trước các hợp giáo liều sọng quả tổ nằm chiáo
hành in thông trạm hành mi sấu, đưa qua hợp và tắc dục.
Hãy bây giờ mạnh, cân trên khai mạnh mẽ hình lưỡa các thỏe thuật,
trong hợp tắc nhân văn.
Cá lưu nhân dân, trong đó hợp tắc sảo dục,
gạo tạp và thỏe thu lực.
Phòng đam, tụi các phạm mi trình và tụi các mì khai mi sụ tìm đã cùng trực kiến,
lấy khi hợp định rất chính phủ rất cộng ngoả sáo ở chủ nghiệp Việt Nam,
và chính phủ liên bằng nà.
Về hợp tắc sây gực nhà mấy định hành lần trên lãnh phủ rất cộng ngoả sáo ở chủ nghiệp Việt Nam.
Cũng trong ngày 21, 8 xe hợp đồng liên bằng thực viện nà ở chủ đồng mắt cơ ra,
khu tưởng phí phủ phạm mi trình đã hợp kiến,
với chủ tịch hợp đồng liên bằng nà và lên tình nà mắt bi trên cô.
Thà cộng của kiến, hành là lãnh đạo bánh đá trà vài trò của cô khu hội hai nước,
trong đó hình ở Mỹ xí hung hỉnh làm liên bằng nà,
trong việc thu tự quả hệ sòng thu hình ở hành lúc sòng phía hạn qua.
Hài bên cũng rất thí, các tụi phát tri vài trò của hai cô khu hội.
Thối hợp đam xác chiến thái các khỏe thuận đã đạt được thứ 2 phí phủ,
trên các lý hợp kinh tế, thương mại, năng lượng, dấu khí,
phó hợp, cơm, an ninh gó phòng, đào tạo môn nếu lực và cơ sở hạ đần.
Hố chở thảo gớ của mắc pháp lý,
giám thuộc đẩy hợp tác hiệu quả trong khi với mới,
đẩy mại hợp tác quan hóa, xuất lịch, chá Luen Rình, và kinh nối hợp tác,
rất các địa phương.
Chú tịch hội đồng liên bằng án nhìn mại,
trong một cạnh hiện này,
thái bên tình thuộc đẩy hợp tác thông lượng, dấu khí,
đông thời, cần có trọng hợp tác nhìn hoặc,
xuất đẩy ra Luen Rình, rắn xuất đào tạo,
xuất lịch, chá luổi bằng quá, để tăng cơm giều biết của những dần thái nước.
Chú tịch và lên tình ra má phíae cô, sau rằng
thái bên tình đẩy mại hợp tác hiệu quả,
các môn quan hệ sản có,
thuộc đẩy về trên lập các cạnh hiện xuất mới,
nhất là sọ khi về nà,
bộ sắp sẽ là đều dưới hạn chính,
để nâng cao hơn nước hiệu quả của những bộ thật tắc này.
Thủ tưởng hạm miếng chính định gì,
hội đồng liên bằng án tiếp tục ủng hộ,
đã được kênh luận lợi cho cộp đồng với Việt Nam tại nhà quan nhập với sợ tại.
Nóng có tích tục cho sự phát triển tình để xác hội liên bằng án
và quá hệ hiệu nghĩ ra hay nước.
Hãy bên cũng chào đổi về tăng cơm của hợp,
tại các diễn đảnh hiệp đá phương.
Như liên miếng nghi vệnh thế giới IPU,
và hội ý đối tắc phía vệnh áo án sép,
có phần biển hoà mình thật tắc và phát triển miếng bình bống.
Thủ tưởng chi phủ phạm miệnh chiếc định gì,
có hội liên bằng án tiếp tục sử lập triển khách quan,
cân mằng, có tiền nói uống lập triển và quan điểm của Việt Nam.
Cúc miếng vụ các khúc ra đúng là mà án sèi ăn,
trong sự liên bình đồng.
Chính cơ sở lợi pháp phút tế,
trong biệt là câu vướng lên hợp phó phế lợp biệt,
trong một lý trí trọng đá em hải.
Chị trở được phát triển và đẹp trế,
cho có trạm trong năm hảo tháng yịch của trong mối bà hành.